have you ever watched an anime and
you're just like man who the [ __ ] is
this
chick what crawled up her vagina this
morning to make her this crabby uptight
[ __ ]
well i'm here to inform everyone of a
horrible disease that hundreds of anime
girls have to go through
every year it's a disease we see all too
often that can cause them extreme pain
uncontrollable mood swings and of course
a high tendency towards violence
their periods what is this 1950s
isn't this so funny isn't this so funny
isn't this so [ __ ] funny so yeah
today i'm going to be talking about
cinderella's now if you've never watched
an anime before
you're probably sitting there thinking
doggie what exactly is a sunderer
well i'm glad you asked you uninformed
little get
this this right here this is what you're
looking for sometimes she can seem like
she's unnecessarily violent and mean
and on the other occasion she can be
sweet that my friends
is a tsundere now it's a common
misconception that cinderella's only
exist in the anime world and
i'm gonna dispel that now because i have
a guaranteed test that will work
100 of the time to tell if a girl that
you know
is cinderelly so okay so here's the test
okay so
you go up to a girl you go up to any
girl and you ask her
hey girl are you asundered now she's
gonna say either one of two things okay
yes or no now if she says yes then
she just admitted to you that she's a
cinderer you know pretty obvious
okay we'll get out of the way now if she
says no
then obviously she's not being true to
her feelings
classic cinderella trait and she's a
[ __ ] sunderer
see what did i tell you what what did i
say
100 of the time it it it works
none of the time many people are big
fans of this character trait and if you
are one person who is unsure if they
ever want to date a cinderer then i
recommend you ask yourself these
questions
were you dropped on the head as a child
do you cry yourself to sleep at night
do you ever feel like hurting yourself
if you answered yes to any of those
then well maybe you should like just
talk to a friend or something i mean
that that
that doesn't really sound too healthy
maybe
you just need some tsundere love it
on second thought that's that's probably
a really bad idea now there are a few
things you need to remember if you ever
want a syndra as there are a few golden
rules you need to understand going into
this
rule number one sunderers are not
[ __ ]
they're misunderstood now believe it or
not this is the most important rule of
all you know it's something that you
just need to remember because
it actually comes from like an old
chinese proverb that i think confucius
said once
you know you just just just repeat after
me again you know cinderellas
are not [ __ ] they're misunderstood
see to a lot of you may just look like
they have severe bipolar disorder
because you know you can be the nicest
guy to them and then they can just turn
around and punch you in the face and you
can buy her this really nice ring
and she likes it and she takes it but
then she decides that she wants to get
with your best mate jason
because you know she just pretended to
care about you and she just wanted you
to buy her stuff
and she's a [ __ ] bed it's fine i'm
i'm fine it's it's all good
i mean they're not real it's all made up
they're not [ __ ] it's all in good fun
i don't even care anymore [ __ ] you
vanessa what i mean to say is
on the surface it may seem like these
people are self-entitled [ __ ] but you
have to remember that for a lot of the
time
something made them this way perhaps it
was someone or something that hurt them
along the way so they just built up this
huge wall around them and they're just
waiting for the right person to break
them out of their shell
and that's the great thing about dating
a cinderer because you have to learn to
have the patience of a buddhist monk
it's a true test of character you know i
mean just [ __ ] jesus
and just punch me in my cheek [ __ ]
the true test of spirit lies with
sundress because as
buddha once said sunderers are not
[ __ ] they are misunderstood
i am one with this feeling
[Music]
i will not let this anger bother me rule
number two
twin tails are sun tails now i don't
know why this is but for some reason in
the anime world if you are in possession
of two pigtails on the side of your head
then it means that either a she's
underage
b she's a cinderere or c she's
underage anna sunderer now ladies don't
think that sunderers are limited to just
females either
there are plenty of male syndras out
there but you know you don't see any of
the guys hitting the girls the same way
that you see cinderella girls hitting
guys
see this this is exactly why we need
feminism it's so that sundrei guys
it's other guys it's it's so that guys
can hit women
without needing to worry wait what
rule number three behind every door is a
slinderee waiting to beat the [ __ ] out
of you this one's more of a safety
warning than anything but
if you're ever in an unfamiliar place
and open the door you better bet that
there's a bunch of half-naked girls
standing on the opposite side of the
door
ready to punch your face off because
they think you're some kind of pervert
or something
yeah what the [ __ ] do they know am i
right lads of course not every girl in
there will be a cinderere but you can
bet that the first girl in there to come
running and hit you smack dab on your
jaw
sundaray now there could just be one
cinderella gunning for your ass or there
could be many it's a little known fact
for what the word for a group of
cinderella is so
here let me enlighten you budding young
viewers with some stimulating cinderella
knowledge that you can amaze your
friends with at your next dinner party
so as we all know singular form is
cinderelly
the plural form is tsunami dere
which directly translates to a [ __ ]
nightmare rule number four
not all cinderellas are worth it now
this is a tie-in with the first rule
remember how i said syndraes are not
[ __ ] but they're misunderstood
well [ __ ] that rules some of them are
[ __ ] and the technical term for those
ones
is trash not everyone can be a
cinderelle god by merely mentioning that
you're a [ __ ] bb barker and she
doesn't like you or some [ __ ]
so a careful man will have to separate
the woman from the girls
the girls from the children the children
from the sexual predator conviction okay
you'll get the point let's take oscar
she seems mean and angry but she went
through some pretty tough [ __ ] as a kid
senjighara she's a sarcastic [ __ ] but
she'll risk her life for you compare
that to this girl who is this girl i
don't even know her name
why she a [ __ ] who knows what will she
ever do for you and then there's arsenal
i mean you saved the entire virtual
world for her and how does she thank you
she [ __ ] dead fishes you for harvest
season
get [ __ ] so to help you determine what
is and isn't
a good cindereray here are my top five
cinderellas for reference
uh number five is uh of course the
classic oscar from evangelion i mean
who doesn't have her on the list uh
number four is holo from spicen wolf not
a full singer i know but you know still
still gods here uh number three is my
air conditioning unit
i can't remember what anime she's from
but you know she could be pretty [ __ ]
cold to me sometimes number two if you
know is uh
bernie sanders he he doesn't really seem
interested in me unless i'm talking
about my student loans but
he really does care and of course the
number one scenario of all time is
donald trump
it was that was a joke guys it was a
joke
i was kidding i was kidding you should
see your faces the person i obviously
meant was hitler
rule number five it's all worth it for
that blush
see if you get past all that if you can
finally break down that tough
harsh exterior to see the boner-inducing
satisfaction
of that blush that shows that they
really do care about you no matter how
much they deny it
see this this [ __ ] guy knows just
remember that it was
all worth it in the first place so can
we just take a quick
minute to appreciate that moment
oh god what have i done with my life and
that's it that's literally everything
you need to know about sunrays
so remember if you should take anything
from this video
just repeat after me sunderers are not
misunderstood
they are [ __ ] wait [ __ ]
[Music]
hey guys before you go i do have a few
quick updates firstly i did release a
new video in my how to unbox series but
for some reason youtube decided that he
didn't want to put it on anyone's
subscription
feed so thanks youtube to anyone who
wasn't informed and wants to watch it
just click on the link on the side here
here's a clip for those of you who
haven't seen just gonna be ready to open
anything up
for people to see see look so let's uh
see what we got here
oh you see here look see there is an
umaru cosplay
secondly i wanted to get the next anime
minutes episode out now actually but i'm
painfully finding out that i can write
much faster than i can edit anyone who's
done bridging before knows that it takes
a [ __ ] time more work than your usual
review
since i have to direct voice actors and
actresses and editing those [ __ ] lip
flaps
so at the moment it's looking more like
a six week schedule unless i completely
drop all the other videos i work on
which i'm sure you guys don't want me to
do or maybe in the future i'm able to
afford an editor to soften the load
fingers cross and lastly this is another
series that i'm starting up that i had a
lot of fun with and it's a lot easier to
produce so if you want to see the next
ultimate anime guide when it's out just
click the link here
anyway that's all i had to say for now i
hope you guys enjoyed the video
i've been giggup and i'll see you all
next time